The question posed by Sultan on the
YouTube is assalamu alaykum sir
walaykumalamra.
My question is is there anyone alive in
this world currently who will not
receive a single goona in janam? If I
understand the question correctly the
questioner is asking that is there
anyone currently living who will not get
a punishment for single gona in janam.
The answer is different. If the question
is is there anyone living today who has
not done a single sin then the answer is
no. The only people who are sinless are
the ambia the messengers of Allah
subhana wa t'ala. So I don't know of
anyone living today in the world who has
not done a single sin. But if the
question is that is there anyone who
will not receive punishment in the jam
inshallah there'll be many. If Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala wants to forgive
someone even after he has committed sin.
If the person repents inshallah Allah is
and there are various hadith in which
the prophet said that if the servants of
Allah sin during night and if they ask
for forgiveness in the morning Allah
will forgive them. If they sin the full
day and they ask forgiveness in night
Allah will forgive them. So if a person
does sin and if he repents sincerely and
there is two types of forgiveness. One
is mak where Allah forgives even Allah
forgives on the day of judgment Allah
will question you for that sin but he
will not punish you for that because
Allah has forgiven you. There's one type
of it is.
So here the is there is forgiveness with
removing any record. Allah will not
question you. If Allah forgives you in
the higher level where Allah will not
question you. So the sin you have done
Allah will not question you on the day
of judgment even about that. So that
type is a higher forgiveness. So is
there any human being who will not be
punished in janam for a single sin? Yes,
there'll be many. Those people who
repent to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala and
who are sincere, inshallah there'll be
many. But if you ask, is there any human
being who has not committed a single sin
now living on the face of the earth?
Then the answer is no. of dancers wish.